It was one of the last tours
of Hot Fuss.
We'd been writing songs
during sound checks.
There was so much need
on our part
to get another record going.
There were some chords
that were floating around
from months before.
A lot of ideas are created
off just a chord progression
that you try
and do something with
and it evolves from there.
That one was
almost accidental.
Towards the end
of a practice.
of the night…
Mark was playing around
with a bass line.
Dave suggested we go up.
He added a note.
So a three-note riff became
a four-note riff
because of something
he suggested.
He was messing around
with these three chords.
I was like: "Oh! Add these
two and then go back to it."
It was
those first three chords
that just, you know,
awakened us.
To have four people be
so in tune
and be able to tap into
the universe
for a second is magic,
you know.
And we're really lucky,
I think,
you know, to have had that
happen at all.
It was just nice to know
that you had something good
that you could get behind,
but the labour came.
At what point do you start
coming up with lyrics?
This is another one
of those strange moments
where I have a lot
come to me right away.
"He doesn't look
a thing like Jesus,
but he talks
like a gentleman
like you imagine
when you were young."
That was the first day.
He doesn't look
a thing like Jesus
but he talks
like a gentleman
like you imagine
when you were young
That made it a lot easier
to write around
because I had something
foundational there.
It helped, I think,
direct me for
the rest of the record, too.
Your ears pricked
by the word "Jesus"
and then you get the
delivery of the guitar riff.
It sort of fulfils a lot of
different emotions.
-It's not obvious.
-No.
And that's what makes
the track brilliant.
Can we climb this mountain?
I don't know
Higher now than ever before
I know we can make it
if we take it slow
Let's take it easy
Easy now, watch it go
I knew there was
some kind of redemption
that was going to be
a thread.
I think it had to do with
things that I was going
through.
Excess and debauchery
in rock and roll, you know,
had been sort of glorified
and glamourised for so long.
You know, we sort of
got thrust into it.
And I realised right away
that that wasn't for me.
One of the things that I
also got in the stands
is a piece of the song that
I don't think is
in the song.
This part.
-Higher, higher
-Yeah!
There's another…
Ok, we took ass
at that lyric.
This is, again, where Flood
and Moulder were crucial.
You know, you need people
to tell you no.
There we go! Saved it from…
loitering
in the bargain bins.
Higher, higher
I said he doesn't look
a thing like Jesus
Thank heavens that didn't
make it onto the final mix.
I'd forgotten about it
until just now.
How'd that get sent to you?
Yeah, why do you have that?
Take his laptop, now.